In Episode 4 of “What If…?,” we see something
we haven’t seen in the series thus far.
The story revolves around Dr. Steven Strange
and his love interest, Dr. Christine Palmer.
From the get-go, it’s obvious this world is
different than the one we know from the MCU
as Steven is head-over-heels in
love with Christine. In “Doctor
Strange,” it’s evident there
are feelings between the two,
but Steven’s ego and narcissism often prevent
their love from blossoming. In Episode 4,
the duo appears to have genuine passion between
them, which isn’t hindered by his cockiness.
The episode begins with the duo taking a ride in
Steven’s car. After some chit-chat, it looks like
they’re about to be in a terrible car crash,
but Steven is able to maneuver his sports car,
so they avoid the accident. Unfortunately,
they’re hit by another vehicle from behind,
which sends them spiraling off the road.
The accident is reminiscent of Steven’s
from the character’s live-action film; the
difference is, this time, he's not alone.
Christine dies in the crash,
and the Watcher tells us how this universe
is different from the one we know:
"In this universe, Steven Strange
didn't lose his hands, but his heart."
Just like in “Doctor Strange,” Steven still
travels to the Kamar-Taj, where he learns about
the mystic arts as he seeks answers to help deal
with his grief. He experiments with the Eye of
Agamotto as he learns time travel is possible
but is warned by Wong to not tinker with it.
"Tinkering with time can weaken
the very fabric of the universe.”
The episode speeds over the death of the
Ancient One and Steven’s defeat of Dormammu
as he becomes the Sorcerer Supreme. It
also leaves out Baron Mordo entirely,
a character essential to the plot in the “Doctor
Strange” film. While these events fall in line
with the ones we’ve seen in the MCU, what happens
next is a complete left turn from what we know.
Steven is still unable to deal with the
loss of Christine two years after her death.
He uses the Eye of Agamotto to travel back to
the night of their car accident and maneuvers his
vehicle differently to avoid the same crash. While
he’s successful, they’re still hit by another car
in an entirely different accident and land in
the same spot, resulting in Christine’s death
yet again. Steven continues to turn back time
over and over — drastically changing the events
of the evening to prevent tragedy. But no matter
what he does, Christine dies every single time.
It’s here we learn from the Ancient One that
Christine’s death is an “absolute point in time.”
She explains that without the death of his
loved one, he would never have mastered the
mystic arts or defeated Dormammu, suggesting
her death is necessary to save the universe.
Steven won’t accept this and goes down a
dangerous path of attempting to reverse
this absolute point in time. He seeks
answers at the Lost Library of Cagliostro.
Steven learns at the library that he
can obtain the power to reverse an
absolute point by gaining the power of other
beings through absorption. His dark path takes
an even darker turn as he summons mythical
beings just so he can absorb their powers.
Steven becomes incredibly strong, even
prompting the Watcher to consider intervening.
Soon, we cut back to an earlier point in the
episode just after Doctor Strange defeats
Dormammu — the moment just before Steven
reverts time. He puts off his time travel,
and when he goes outside, he sees his reality
slowly starting to wither away as buildings and
people appear to disintegrate. The Ancient One
shows up again, and we learn of a new twist.
It turns out, the Ancient One split
reality into two timelines the moment
Steven used the Eye of Agamotto to travel
back in time using dark magic. This allowed
two Stevens to simultaneously exist in one
universe, and shortly after learning this,
the Doctor Stranges come face to face.
One fights for the sake of the universe,
and the other fights to save Christine
by reversing that absolute point in time.
It’s a brutal battle between the two, with dark
Steven coming out victorious as he absorbs the
power of his counterpart. He is successful
in stopping Christine’s death that night,
but that choice ends up decimating the entire
universe. Steven learns too late that reversing
Christine’s death changes everything, and in this
new reality everything crumbles and he loses his
love yet again. Steven talks to the Watcher
as the universe disintegrates and admits he’s
always felt his presence. In a last-ditch effort,
he begs him to intervene and to set things right.
"You, you can stop this. Please, fix this."
But the Watcher refuses, saying that
interfering with time and events only
leads to further destruction, so he watches the
world crumble as Steven and Christine perish.
As we learned in the three episodes prior, one
decision can change absolutely everything. In
Episode 4, it’s more evident than ever as the
Watcher explains that these choices can destroy
the entire universe. Clearly, some choices bear
more weight than others. Steven’s response to
losing the use of his hands in “Doctor Strange”
was substantially different from the reaction
he had to the death of Christine. Both stories
saw him triumph against Dormammu and become the
Sorcerer Supreme, but his partner’s
death was too much for him to bear,
which led to all-out destruction
through his always evident arrogance.
While the difference in this story was Christine’s
death over the destruction of his hands, it was
ultimately Steven’s decision to reverse that
absolute point in time which ended the universe.
We’re still left wondering will the Watcher
ever intervene? This is the most we’ve seen him
interact with a story thus far, but if he wouldn’t
intervene as the universe was being destroyed,
what situation might we see that would
force him to step in and do something?
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.